[Musique]
je m'appelle rex je suis le corps il à
rennes ah ouais c'est le prince philip
qui m'a offert à sa majesté
je suis tellement populaire que sa
majesté a fait mettre mon portrait sur
un blog
c'était vraiment celui tu dis que tu es
commente intérêts ici c'est fait une
très grosse bêtise je crois bien que
ceci et je me suis enfui
je suis mort charlie a tout manigancé
maintenant c'est lui qui va devenir le
numéro à mai mois au palais de
buckingham tu as aucune chance mon pote
[Musique]
comme le dit le proverbe
l'union fait la force ensemble nous
serons livre
bravo c'est partant adam nous mettons
discours était super